we've just heard sort of an unrelenting
litany of negative news from around the
world and markets take us behind those
overall numbers what is going on well I
think actually the markets are being
pawed by the bear right now pod pod but
they're going to be mauled you know in
the bano and the reason for it is this
is not just the end of a bull market I
think it's the end of an era the end of
a worldwide era in which central banks
printed money injected liquidity
supported markets manipulated and
intruded in the pricing of financial
assets like never before and what it did
was create a massive credit expansion in
the world that's stopping we had 40
trillion of debt in the world in 1995 we
have 225 trillion today everywhere is at
peak debt china is the united states is
europe obviously is secondly the central
banks are all out of power a powder dry
powder the fed is painted itself into a
corner and now we hear no the market
saying no interest rates in the creases
in the coming year that's a hundred
months effectively at zero money market
costs you will destroy a financial
system on eight years of zero cost money
China is actually fighting desperately a
massive capital outflow which means they
have to tighten their in quantitative
tightening that's what's supporting the
currents okay well we need to break this
down the gaming this is an overall
you're painting a bear market picture a
recession on the horizon global
recession on the horizon recession
coming to the United States much sooner
than anyone realizes because they're
misled by the lagging and phony
employment numbers that are put out by
the BLS every month if you look at what
counts what employers are paying into
Uncle Sam daily and payroll tax
withholding it is turned negative on a
real basis after inflation is run
in the last four weeks negative four and
a half percent that has always been an
indicator that recession is coming that
a big pull back is happening in the
economy because the whole narrative
about how awesome everything is has been
so this is a powerful and very negative
picture we've had person after person
after person come in with a very
different picture saying the chances
recession are very limited in fact just
yesterday Goldman came out said twenty
five percent chance or less there's a
recession what is it that you see that
none of them see what I see is that out
of the last seven recessions Wall Street
and Goldman in particular is picked has
predicted none of them over the last
three or four huge downturns that we've
had both in the market in the economy
the Fed had no clue it's coming the
mainstream narrative which is dominated
by a Keynesian view that the labor
market drives the whole GDP is not only
failing but it is so completely wrong
that they can't see what they're looking
in a rearview mirror and they can't see
what's coming right at us which is a
global deflation as a result of massive
over investment in everything from iron
ore mines you know the container ships
that resulted from cheap capital in
cheap bank credit that the central
bank's generated over 20 years we're in
something new it's closer to the 1930s
than anything we saw before in the sense
that we're going to have a cap X
depression and capex is really what
drives profits capex is we at jobs at
caterpillar pay a big wage capex jobs
disappear and as an enormous impact on
the on the economy so all of us can be
wrong if you're wrong how are you on why
you're wrong I mean look at the US
consumer is not nearly as leverage the
average household's not nearly as
leverage as it was in two thousand 2008
2007 2008 correct they have more money
spent they've got
money because gasoline prices are lower
I think the point on that is they were
so hideously over-leveraged in 208 that
a bad thing happened today there is
still more than 13 trillion of debt
mortgage credit card etc on the consumer
it's still a hundred and eighty percent
of wage and salary income historically
it was eighty percent so we're still way
out in the woods most consumers not the
top 10% they go to Macy's and they were
buying stuff and now they're not but the
bottom ninety percent of households are
living hand-to-mouth sixty percent of
them don't even have any cash savings
and they aren't they haven't unlevered
at all and so therefore this idea that
the consumer is so healthy I think it's
just wall street propaganda